we've been with this family you can see
him now Muhammad he's a Syrian student
he's been living here for the last 10
years he fled the war 10 years ago with
his family and all of them live along
this road which is this just destroyed
it's just apocalyptic scenes all around
us and right now he's looking for the
body of his three and a half year old
cousin ainor her whole family survived
they were pulled out of this wreckage
days ago and they were just waiting to
hear from the only daughter that remains
in this building and they've been
looking for her for the for the last
seven days since the earthquake happened
this is as close as they've gotten to
the room that she was sleeping in when
the earthquake hit and we've you know as
I said we've spent time with these
people we know how long they spend
looking for their loved ones they're
they've set up camp up here between two
of the buildings that their family lived
in they they sleep here they eat here
and it's just this unrelenting search
for something for any sign and and I
think the thing that's that's the most
devastating but also the most you know
all inspiring is the fact that even if
it's a body even if if the child isn't
living if their family members aren't
living they are Keen to honor the dead
they are Keen to have a chance to
transfer the body back to Syria to be
buried you know Muhammad told me just
earlier this we we want to be buried in
our land Syria is where we belong and
even if we even if they're not living
just that privilege to bury the dead and
give them the burial that they deserve